[Music]
[Music]
morning everyone it's seven o'clock in
the uk welcome wherever you're watching
us around the world this morning the
last group matches for the euros we
expected
drama and surprises but not quite like
this with
both the england and scotland teams on
kovid alert
and now a call from one prime minister
to pull the final from wembley
because of rising cases fresh questions
too
over travel quarantine rules this
morning the health secretary matt
hancock joins us
very shortly indeed in addition to that
now when she should have been
celebrating her 60th birthday
we consider what this very special woman
achieved
diana at 60 the new documentary
featuring the princess's friends and
those
who worked with her tries to paint a
picture of what her life
might have been we're joined by the
director and
okay jensen we need to retire
moving at a fast pace we're joined by
the formula
of former i should say formula one world
champion jensen button
to find out why he wants to learn from
the past it's tuesday the 22nd of june
kovid at the euros as two england
players self-isolate
a call from italy's pm to pull the final
from wembley
because of rising cases in the uk
neglected for decades how working-class
white children have been forgotten
reef rau are called to put the great
barrier reef on a danger list
but australia says no
the pressures of fame we meet andy
murray who opens up about mental health
and whether or not this will be his last
wimbledon in a broadcast exclusive
comments on your personality or how you
might look or how you might talk and all
of those things like
yeah like when you're 18 you're not
prepared for that
and it's looking fine for many areas
today slightly warmer than recently as
well
but some areas will see rain i'll have
the details for you later
good morning everyone a covered alert at
the euro 2020 tournament and plenty of
fresh questions
over travel too in this morning's
newspapers and a report that people
who've had two jobs
may be set to benefit from quarantine
free travel
lots to put to the health secretary matt
hancock who is on the program very
shortly indeed
but first italy's prime minister mario
draghi wants
the euro 2020 final to be moved from
wembley
to rome because of britain's rising
covid infections
meanwhile england and scotland are
having to rethink their squad selections
for tonight's games
england's ben chilwell and mason mount
are self-isolating after coming into
contact
with scotland's billy gilmore who tested
positive
for kervid19 after the two countries met
last friday meanwhile have any plans for
a summer holiday abroad
got gloomier well yesterday the prime
minister played down suggestions
a widespread relaxation of restrictions
on international travel
stressing it's going to be a difficult
year for travel
first let's get more on the coveted
alert at the football a blow
despite england qualifying for the
knockout phase of euro 2020 without even
kicking
a ball today let's find out more about
it our correspondent
shaman freeman powell is outside wembley
stadium for us
hello to you good morning covert issues
this morning
good morning good morning yes it's very
chaotic
and both sides are going to have many
questions that need
answering for tonight's game as you said
on friday it was a huge game for both
england and scotland and both of them
are
expecting to play tonight but with billy
uh gilmore testing positive
it's thrown up many many questions so he
was the man of the match for scotland
on friday and in the midst of
celebrations he was seen celebrating
with fellow chelsea teammates uh ben
chilwell
and mason mount and it seems that after
those celebrations
that's actually what caused those two
players to self-isolate
as there are questions as to why other
players haven't been asked the same
questions
and as you say it does throw up some
questions about these big tournaments
generally
and about whether or not they should be
going ahead and as you just mentioned
the italians prime minister
has recently come out calling for the
games to be moved from wembley
over to rome and here's what you have to
say
yes i will try to stop the final being
held in a country where infections
are rising quickly thank you
i wonder how that might go down not only
with england fans but also
the um the fa here and also other
football organizations they're not going
to be pleased about the italians saying
let us have the final are they
no i think it could be expected for him
to say that there are obviously reasons
why people want it
moving to rome but it does make things
more complicated for people here
as they are now going to have to think
about what to do if the same thing
happened to them
okay it's good to talk to you it's a bit
noisy there isn't it we'll let you go
and get a cup of tea we'll chat to you
in the next hour thanks very much
thanks a lot um quick look at what's
happening as far as the latest daily
coronavirus data
is concerned this is how it's looking
today there have been 10
633 new coronavirus cases
five more deaths have been reported that
means the total number of people
who've died within 28 days of a positive
test now stands
at 127 981
another 163 750 people have received
their first vaccination
and 109 000 and a bit have had their
second vaccine in total more than 31
million people
have received both doses of a covered
vaccine that's
nearly 60 percent of the adult
population
lots to us then the uh health secretary
when he joins us
in just a few moments time we're going
to ask him about
social care as well of course don't we
uh and uh
in addition to that what he thinks about
the euros he's joining us now hello to
you mr hancock thank you for joining us
on the programme this morning it's good
to see you the aim of the
at this at the building hello hello mr
hello mr hancock hello hello
hello how are you we're great we're live
on the telly just at the moment here we
go
can you hear me okay yep we're live on
the telly mr hancock it's k burley
talking to you
um confirmation of two
jabs and potentially that means that we
can
straight off the amber list we don't
have to quarantine when is that going to
happen
well this hasn't been clinically advised
yet we're working on it
and we're working on plans to
to to essentially allow the vaccine to
bring back some of the freedoms that
have had to be restricted to keep people
safe i mean after all that's the whole
purpose of the vaccination program
it's why it's so important that
everybody who
every adult goes out and gets the jab
and if you've had one job that you go
and
that you go and get to because that's
where the full protection comes from
okay working on it does that mean
potentially by august so at least people
might be able to have some semblance
of a family foreign holiday this year
well we'll get there when it's
safe to do so we want to do this right
we want to do this
carefully and properly but of course we
do want to get those freedoms back
and that's the whole point of the
vaccination program so when i'm in a
position to be able to
say something more concrete than we will
do but it is absolutely something we're
working on it's something i want to see
presently costing something like 600
million pounds a day to the economy
so every day counts
well yes but the pandemic here at home
has
huge costs in terms of lives in terms of
uh the economy
and so protecting this country from
from the uh what can happen
the variance we've seen around the world
that is a very very important part of
managing this pandemic now
thankfully because of the vaccination
program we've been able to free up a
huge number of the restrictions here at
home
we're on track to deliver the
step four the further openings on the
19th of july
which is good um but we're also
looking to see how we can replace the
protections that
are currently there with the
restrictions with protections that come
from the vaccine
with respect to international travel as
well but it is more difficult
freeing up international travel we have
one of the tightest border control
systems in the world and we have that
because we want to protect this amazing
progress we've made at home with the
vaccination program okay
perhaps one option will be the new app
that
you want to talk to us about could that
act as a vaccine passport
well we we we can now all of us
see our vaccine status see your testing
status
on the nhs app and we've seen this
massive uptake of the nhs
app and there's two the one that you use
to check into venues 25 million people
have downloaded that
a smaller number six million people have
now downloaded the main nhs app
and on that you can show whether you've
had the have the jabs
and and that is a that is a it's
important because we know other
countries are going to say that they
want proof that you've been vaccinated
before you go
so when travel is opened up we are going
to make sure people have got that
that ability to prove it so if you go
into the app store right now okay you
can download the nhs app
it connects up with your gp records it
means that you're
more in control of your health data
which is which is important and one of
the big learnings from the pandemic
one of the things that we're
strengthening with the data strategy
we're setting out today
but it will also mean that you can see
your vaccination status
and see your any tests you've done
recently
to be able to um to help prove that you
haven't got the coronavirus so it's all
part of using modern technology to help
to manage this pandemic as well as
possible
okay yep i do that and i can see that
i've had both vaccines i've had that
app for a long time i'm seeing that as a
vaccine passport for me
me to be able to prove to other nations
if i travel overseas
that i am um i've had both my jabs and
i'm 100
invincible um talk to me about um dido
harding if you would she wants to run
the national health service
um and i believe uh that you are keen on
her
doing that um just looking at a track
record it's not great though is that um
track and trace not fantastic as my
viewers will know
uh her roles at talk talk and will worse
weren't um
ringing endorsements for her career why
do you think she would be a good leader
of the nhs
well i'm absolutely not going to get
into any individuals who put their name
forward we have an open competition
for who is going to be the next chief
executive of the nhs is an incredibly
important job running
you know one of the most important
institutions in the country probably the
most loved
and um so we've we're looking broadly
and we've invited applications from
across the board
for who can do that job it's a tough job
and
simon stevens has done it very well over
the past eight years
but we need to make sure that that the
nhs has the right leader
and we need to make sure that the nhs
looks forward and
you know the data strategy for instance
we're publishing today from the nhs
is all about how we can harness modern
technology
to make sure the care you receive is
better because
you know anybody who's used the nhs will
have had the experience of going in and
having to give their information over
and over again
and make sure that we can organize the
nhs as well as possible using modern
technology so yeah the nhs is
about dido hardy look forward my
questions about diedo harding why is she
a good candidate
well as i said we'll look at all of the
candidates who put their names
forward and i haven't seen the uh
the shortlist that's the whole process
is being run by the
nhs board and we're doing we're being
very thorough and we've invited
applications from right across the world
okay okay talk to me uh about um social
care
uh we heard from your predecessor jeremy
hunt in the daily mail yesterday he says
it's a do or die
moment really and we heard that from the
prime minister two years ago
two years ago on the doorstep of number
10. you had a meeting planned
with the prime minister and the
chancellor to talk about the social care
crisis why has it been postponed
well the prime minister has been
absolutely clear
that we're going to publish the plan
for the future of social care this year
our commitment is there in the manifesto
to deliver on social care in this
parliament
and we deliver on our commitments right
we were elected to get brexit done and
we delivered all that
we said we'd protect the nhs through the
pandemic and we've delivered on that
we're currently delivering millions and
millions and millions of
vaccines uh every week and we've
committed to making sure every adult can
get a job
we've delivered on that so we will
deliver on social care in terms of the
ins and outs of the
in terms of the ins and outs of you know
the internal processes of course i'm not
going to get into that but what your
viewers
can rest assured is that we will deliver
the plan for the reform of social care
that as you said in the question is long
overdue
okay we only have a limited amount of
time my question is why was the meeting
postponed
well what i'm telling you okay is i'm
absolutely not going to get into
uh diary management issues what i'm
going to tell you about is this
schedule given how important it is
when's it been rescheduled for
well you wouldn't it could possibly
expect me to
answer questions about private meetings
and i'm
well i'm not going to but what i am
going to do is deliver the reform of
social care that people want to see
naturally we have to delay this sorry
why not
you said it's long overdue why are you
not telling us
when the meetings are going to be uh
when you're going to discuss with the
prime minister
and the chancellor of the exchequer when
something that was promised two years
ago
a meeting has been postponed you can't
tell us when it's been rescheduled for
meantime something like uh i think i'm
right in saying 18
000 pensioners a week of finding
themselves in a position where they're
being moved
from hospital to social care and they
don't know whether they're going to lose
their houses
because they the prime minister's not
delivered on his prof on his promise
of dealing with social care
well i don't know where to start with
the total rubbish in that question okay
firstly
um i i'm absolutely not going to get
into
diary management i talk to the prime
minister every single day
and we're working very closely together
on the delivery of this
policy um the but the second thing is
um we absolutely were working on the
plan before the pandemic struck
but you all understand and your viewers
will undoubtedly understand that when
the pandemic struck it was all hands on
deck
to to you know to protect lives and to
to get us out of this as fast as
possible and the vaccine is doing that
and the prime minister has committed to
delivering this plan before the end of
the year
and we're going to do that hopefully
this isn't as rubbish a question then is
the money there have you managed to have
that conversation with the chancellor
well of course the the question in terms
of social care
is both in terms of how we can best
make sure that people get the care that
they need in the setting they need
uh whether that's in their own home with
care coming into their own home
or of course in a care home
or and in terms of how that's paid for
and who pays for it there are many
injustices in the current system that we
want to
tackle and that's one of the reasons
this is such a
complex piece of work but it's also one
of the reasons it's such an important
piece of work and we're absolutely
determined to deliver on it and we're
going to deliver on it okay let's let's
try this one
um the royal yacht set to cost 200
million
pounds that should we have that or
should we have
that money to pay for 8 000 extra nurses
for a year
yeah well i'm obviously not the minister
responsible for the royal yacht but what
i can tell you is i think it's a
brilliant idea
and it's a brilliant idea because it's
how we can help to sell britain
abroad and you only need to do a small
encourage a small amount of trade in
order to pay for
a yacht like this over and over again
and by taking the yacht
essentially displaying britain in
countries around the world in harbors
around the world
and from you know in new york to
singapore
you can you can sell what is great about
this country and great to invest in this
country
and we've got so much to sell you know
the middle part of the 21st century is a
fantastic time for this country if we
get this right
and i think that making the investment
to be able to go and sell britain around
the world
is money well spent and i think it will
repay itself
over and over and over again so although
it's not my area
um you can tell that i'm quite i'm an
enthusiast for this
um and i think that it's long overdue
and i'm absolutely
thrilled that that we're making progress
on delivering it because i think it'll
be great value for money in the narrow
sense but it's also very very important
that we sell out or sell britain around
the world
okay okay uh interestingly her majesty
is not a fan uh so why don't you just
call it a yacht
well i i i i don't think you know and um
and i certainly don't know of those
of those opinions but what i do know is
that
this country has a huge amount of
opportunity
we've got to get through this pandemic
and get out of it of course and we've
got to build back and learn the lessons
from it
but in terms of trading with the whole
world with all the trade deals that
we're striking at the moment
we've got a huge amount of opportunity
and we've got to make the most of it
okay i know you've got to go let me ask
you very quickly before you do um the
italian prime minister wants to nab
the euro 2020 finals away from us
because he says that we've got too many
cases of
covid here in the uk what would you say
in response to him
well i i think these euros are going
very well the final set to be at wembley
and i i was at wembley on friday night
it was
great to hear the the noise of the
crowds again
and this is obviously something that uh
that oliver dowden the
culture secretary is working closely
with uefa on
uh but i think we've got a we've got a
great setup and
uh it's uh and i i hope that either
england or scotland or wales
or potentially two are in the final that
would be absolutely brilliant it's great
to see uh wales through
it's great to see last night england are
through and um and
maybe i hope scotland can get through as
well that would be
that would be brilliant if all three got
to the last 16 that would be an amazing
performance for
for the home nations a diplomat and a
politician to the end it's always good
to talk to you mr hancock thank you for
joining us this morning
still to come on the programme for you
at 7 30 the shadow home secretary nick
thomas simmons will be joining us as
coronavirus cases continue to climb
8 30 we'll hear from aviation consultant
robert boyle about the need to help and
free up the travel industry
and before that i'm going to be speaking
to f1 world champion jensen button about
his highlights
of a hundred years of motorsport
meantime latest boring figures are just
in from the office for
national statistics this is what they
are looking like helen and smith has
them for us hey helena tell us more
morning k yes we've got figures in uh
for the month of may of what the
government borrowed
uh and what it owed of course the
context a pandemic
that's wrought habit with the economy
millions and millions spent by
the government propping it up via things
like the furlough scheme so
in the month of may uh net borrowing
what the government borrowed
was 24.3 billion pounds now that was
slightly down on what it was in april
slightly down on what it was
in march but nevertheless still the
second highest borrowing
for the month of may on record second
only to may
2020 when of course the pandemic begun
net debt what the government essentially
owes that's been creeping up
as well throughout the last 18 months
it's currently at 99.2 percent of gdp so
put another way it's almost 100
of the total value of all products and
services in the economy what the
government currently owes its net debt
uh it's worth saying as well that the
financial year that we've just concluded
in march
uh the figures for that have been ever
so slightly revised in terms of
uh the net borrowing but nevertheless uh
our borrowing in this country is still
uh was in the last financial year at the
highest levels seen since the second
world war so these are really really big
numbers and it all matters
because the chance of the exchequer
under huge amounts of pressure
to pay for not just the recovery things
like the education catch-up
program we know the government
criticized for that not giving enough
for health catch up
but also for some of those big pledges
and promises you were discussing there
okay
with the health secretary the yacht
social care things like the pensions
triple look
the money for this all has to come from
somewhere the tories want to be seen as
the party that can balance the books but
these are still
huge huge numbers very difficult indeed
indeed so and thanks for getting the
memo about wearing emerald green this
morning helena
see you later thanks a lot a report by
mp i'm kidding a report by mps has
described this systemic neglect of white
working-class children calling them
the forgotten the report attacks the use
of the term white
privilege claiming it contributes to the
failings
of these children as they persistently
underperform compared with those in
other ethnic groups
it also accuses the department for
education of failing to acknowledge the
problem
here's our home editor jason farrell
at outwood academy in barnsley 42
of the predominantly white children come
from disadvantaged backgrounds
and educators here are unsurprised by
the findings
that the academic performance of white
working-class children
is low compared to poor children from
other ethnicities
i've seen great evidence for example
that newcomer newcomers to the country
the optimism that they come with
can often see education as the route out
of poverty
but for too many communities that are
established they don't see that same
level of importance behind education
poor white children on free school meals
do badly throughout primary
into secondary school and the impact on
outcomes is dramatic for example
73 percent of chinese pupils on free
school meals
get into higher education with black
african kids from lower incomes it's 59
and black caribbean it's half that at 32
but with white children from the same
low income bracket
it's half again just 16
get into higher education the report
authors conclude
that policies should be directed towards
helping this group
and controversially also say the term
white privilege
shouldn't be used as it contributes to
what they call
systemic neglect of white working-class
children
the concept of white privilege is
entirely
wrong-headed it's wrong-headed because
it implies collective guilt
when it should be in the individuals who
are responsible for acts of racism
he's really saying to the single parent
who might live
in a small bed sit in a in a flat in my
constituency of harlow
that she automatically is someone of
white privilege i mean this is why this
has got to be stopped
but others argue that the issues facing
ethnic groups
shouldn't even be a factor in the
question of how to lift
the attainment of white school children
it seems
more like a culture war bomb
than an actual desire to create
betterment within our society for
example white working-class people
are not an ethnic group and throughout
the whole report it refers to white
working-class people as an effort group
they are
an economically challenged section of an
ethnic group which is white people
and one of the problems that we have is
that these debates are always predicated
upon the fallacy
which is white working-class people
versus ethnic minorities
see you tomorrow it all plays into the
politics of race
and left behind communities the
government says it is leveling up
but also that as the largest group white
disadvantaged
children benefit most from schemes such
as the pupil premium
jason farrell sky news
[Music]
other stories making news for you this
morning on the programme
at las vegas raiders star carl nasib has
become the first
active nfl player to come out as gay the
28 year old announced the news in a
short video posted on his instagram page
he also said that he has donated a
hundred thousand dollars to the trevor
project which is a group that seeks to
prevent
suicide among the lgbtq community
just want to take a quick moment to say
that i'm gay i've been meaning to do
this for a while now
but i finally feel comfortable enough to
get it off my chest um
i really have the best life i got the
best family friends and job a guy could
ask for
i'm a pretty private person so i hope
you guys know that i'm really not doing
this for attention
um i just think that representation and
visibility are so important
good for you young man now there's a rye
brewing over australia's great
barrier reef the united nations wants it
added to a list of
endangered world heritage sites due to
the impact of climate change
the australian government says no the
reef
is an icon internationally
and we are here to fight for the reef
and we are here to challenge the
decision
when it comes up for final consideration
in the world heritage committee
in about the third week of july this
decision was made as i said
without due process it was made on the
basis of a desktop review
it hasn't even used the latest data
we've got australian institute of marine
science
data coming out that's showing really
strong work in the recovery
from the bleaching events that have
occurred
well here's sky news australia political
reporter trudy mcintosh
the australian government believe that
they have been singled out with this new
report by unesco saying that the great
barrier reef heritage status
is now in danger the reason behind this
is they don't believe the process has
been transparent the
environment minister says her officials
behind the scenes were given
no indication in recent days that there
was about to be this change to the
listing
yes it is a draft change at the moment
the final detail on this will be decided
next month in china but it is china that
is one of the reasons behind this
australia has been engaged
in a diplomatic war of words with
beijing for quite some time now
ministers in australia not even able to
get a phone call back from their chinese
counterpart
it's my understanding from behind the
scenes the australian government fears
that this is potentially
another form of retribution leveled
against australia as part of a campaign
of coercion
that china is the chair of this unesco
body there is a fear within the
australian government
about the growing influence that china
has over the unesco body
and that that potentially is seeping
into these other
environmental issues when it comes to
the reef it's certainly not a universal
position though within australia the
opposition
here does not believe these two issues
are linked
i want to show you these pictures hms
queen elizabeth the pride of the british
navy has been showing off its firepower
in the eastern mediterranean there you
go on its first ever deployment its f-35
jets are involved in operations against
remaining islamic state fighters
in iraq according to the naval
commanders they're also involved in a
catamase game with russian jets in the
area
the 65 000 ton carrier is supporting
live military operations on the ground
for the first time
in more than two decades beautiful isn't
she
uh let's find out what's happening as
far as the weather is concerned it was
miserable yesterday
nas i got soaking wet through what's
happening today
bit wet this morning okay but actually
it is looking mostly fine and dry across
many areas for today and feeling
slightly warmer than recently in the
sunshine too
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it's looking mostly fine
and dry across many parts of the uk and
ireland for today
with some good spells of sunshine i'm
feeling slightly warmer than recent days
as well
but and there's always a but there will
be some rain around
for northwestern areas later and this
morning it's a cloudy and wet start
across many central and southern parts
of
england across these areas as well it's
less cold compared to elsewhere where
it's sunny and mainly dry but it really
is quite chilly in some spots across
northern parts of scotland temperatures
drop down to minus 2.4 degrees celsius
with an
air frost there which is quite unusual
for this time in june
now going into this afternoon and the
cloud will eventually thin and break as
that rain eases away
very slowly across southern parts of
england so eventually these areas will
become dry and brighter but it may stay
quite cloudy and cool
for the far southeast of england parts
of kent for example for much of the
afternoon
elsewhere sunny spells developing
feeling warm but cloudy wet and windy
across the far northwest of ireland and
scotland later
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
if you've only just joined us you've
missed the health sector being a bit
testy with me this morning already and
it's not even half past seven find out
what he had to say
in a short time coming up after the
break we are going to be a chatting
uh about the continuing fight against
kovid speaking to labour's
shadow home secretary nick thomas
simmons that's
[Music]
i'm greg milam skye's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
i've seen the dark side of america
[Music]
[Applause]
they say they can't go back to myanmar
yet if they do
they fear they'll be killed we take you
to the heart of the stories that shape
our world
if there is a bigger explosion this area
would be
in the danger zone
these traffic jams snakes for hours up
and down this hillside
we know that 800 000 people have been
displaced i think experiencing the two
million person march in hong kong that
was a moment
[Applause]
[Music]
police have been firing tear gas
[Music]
sky news bangkok
hello my name is nadja frontier
my name is ryan matthews i'm the marine
assistant
at rather a research station which is to
the west of the west antarctic peninsula
so far i've been here for five months
and it is an absolutely wonderful
[Music]
experience
my name is fatima zazile the founder of
ikisa from kuwait where we face many
environmental problems related to waste
pollution the frustration
and lack of information we are
collecting recyclables
from houses schools and businesses in
order to recycle them
[Music]
exchange if you recycle to get a tree
morning again health secretary's been on
the program he has told us that the
government is working on plans to allow
extra freedoms for those people who are
double vaccinated
boris johnson said yesterday it was
going to be a difficult year for travel
but matt hancock told me this morning
that ministers
are keen to reap the benefits of the
vaccine rollout and give freedoms back
to the public
we'll get there when it's safe to do so
we want
to do this right we want to do this
carefully and properly
but of course we do want to get those
freedoms back
that's the whole point of the
vaccination program so when i'm in a
position to be able to
say something more concrete than we will
do but it is absolutely something we're
working on it's something i want to see
uh and joining us is the shadow home
secretary nick thomas simmons
hello to you first time we've chatted in
face to face it's great of you to come
in
on the show this morning thank you just
hearing there about the ambulance double
vaccinated potentially
it means that you could travel if you
can prove that your double vaccination
how does labour feel about that
well firstly good morning kane great to
be joining you look
of course we want to see international
travel
opened up when it is safe to do so but
my concern about this proposal
is we are yet again going from one
particular proposal
to another we lurch from one thing then
we lurch to another
what i've been asking for is a
comprehensive plan from the government i
think at this moment
yes have that growing green list but
i've been arguing for some time that the
ambulance has to in effect go into the
red list
that you need to have that comprehensive
hotel quarantine system to protect
the gains of the british people over the
past 12 months but also to guard against
variance from overseas which is the big
threat to our vaccine rollout so what
benefits should there be
obviously uh health benefits for having
two jobs what about the social benefits
yes and we of course want to be clear
that having
the vaccination having the two jabs is a
really positive thing
to getting our lives back to normal i
can see how that
could be part of a reopening of
international travel
but what we have to see now is firstly
let's protect the vaccine rollout let's
get that comprehensive
system in place and let's have a proper
strategy not government ministers giving
one idea change their minds going to
another
now you're probably on your way here so
you didn't maybe see the health sector
being very testy with me earlier on when
i was asking him about social care
and why the meeting has been cancelled
between the prime minister
and the chancellor of the exchequer he
said that was private and it was nothing
to do with me or my viewers
what does labour want to see as far as
social care is concerned when do they
want to know
what the plans will be for our elderly
frankly we should
already have known boris johnson when he
became prime minister when was it july
2019
actually spoke about social care on the
steps of ten
downing straight now social care is one
of the
great political challenges of my
generation of politicians
if you like how we are going to make
sure that everyone
has that dignity in retirement and has
that
care that they actually need this should
be an urgent priority for the government
it is everything to do
with you and your viewers and the
government should be open about the
meeting
and need to bring forward plans as a
matter of urgency at two years ago when
he made those promises on the doorstep
of number 10 nobody saw the pandemic
coming where's the money going to come
from well
look it isn't a question of whether or
not
we can afford for everybody to have the
care they need it's a necessity that
everybody has
the care that they need and it isn't as
if
this is a new challenge of course
there's been the pandemic and the
different challenges
that that has brought but we've known
that social care was an enormous
challenge
because of our aging population because
of the positive thing of people
living longer that's been known for
years and years
that promise was made by boris johnson
the steps of downing street and he
should deliver it
uh i know you want to talk about uh
windrush anniversary of windrush um you
feel that the government
has failed the people um uh of windrush
and many barbadians as well we're going
to be speaking to some people
a little bit later on about this very
subject what sort of support do you want
to see
i want to see the whole scheme handed
over to
an independent body and i think that has
to happen
because the home office has
comprehensively failed so this scheme
was set up
back in 2019. frankly victims were
traumatized in the first place
the scheme is re-traumatizing them i've
spoken
to victims i know their complete lack of
confidence in this scheme
in that time only 687
people have been compensated 21 people
have died without actually receiving
their compensation
and the actual offers have been
appallingly low no wonder the national
audit office
gave a damning report on this scheme
last month
so the time has come to give it to an
independent body so that people can get
the justice they deserve
how frustrating is it for you to be when
you be so passionate about your position
and about politics and about injustice
in the united kingdom
knowing that it doesn't look as though
anytime soon you guys are going to be in
power and batley and spen
is not going your way either which is
the by-election next thursday well
first you should never take voters for
granted and we will see what happens
in battle didn't you in cheshire but
uh well look i mean there's a very
particular set of circumstances in
cheshire and ambition
hs2 planning and other issues and it's
not a seat that is in any sense got a
history of labour voting but at the same
time
obviously i wanted to have done better
in cheshire and amisham i want to do
better
all around the country but i think it
would be a huge mistake to make these
assumptions about the results of
elections whether it's the battle and
spend by-election
whether it's the next general election
uh i am passionate about changing the
country kierstahl is passionate about
changing the country
we will be putting that case to voters
are you going to win battle in spain
i sincerely hope so we got an excellent
candidate i i never take voters for
granted and i think making predictions
like that is to do that but i know we've
got an excellent candidate up there in
kim ledbet is running a fantastic
campaign looking forward to getting that
supporter myself the next couple years
how are you feeling about a royal yacht
look i think
we really do seriously need to see
whether this
is affordable and his value for money
we've heard the prime minister talking
about the idea of a royal yacht
we've then had it appear as the
chancellor concerned about where the
money's coming from
it now appears that the money may be
coming from the ministry of defence but
that was a
budget we already understood there was a
black hole in
so i hope that we will actually have
something that resembles a proposal that
we can look at
to see if this actually represents value
for money and let's see if you agree uh
with matt hancock on this one
um the prime minister of italy
wants to take the euro 2020 final offers
he doesn't think it should be at wembley
because of the rising cases of covert in
the uk
well i i don't agree with the prime
minister of italy i would like to see
the uh of obviously i'd like to see the
final of the the euros i thought you'd
agree with matt hancock did you
know it's a new novel experience for me
uh but
look i think that uh on you know you the
euro 2020 happening now as it is in euro
2021
uh it's been been a great tournament so
far wales of course already through to
the
the last 16 and of course i'd love to
see the final here uh carried out of
course safely and wales to lift the
trophy let's hope so
well okay it's good to talk to you
thanks for coming in to see us as i said
appreciate it thanks a lot still to come
on the program for you you can catch up
on any
of our interviews here on sky news today
uh
all you need to do is to go online just
like that find us on our mobile app as
well
uh and you can go to the live blog to
watch the program live
and you can catch up on the interviews
on my twitter
as well that's at k burley
lot to talk about tomorrow why do you
want to stop good morning kate should we
start with social care yes matt hancock
bit tetchy about
why this thing that we thought was
happening with the prime minister and
rishi sunak yesterday
was called off the bottom line is they
promised a plan we have prepared
two years ago that's what boris johnson
said of course the pandemic
has intervened they've now promised it
by the end of this year but i understand
the row that's going on in government at
the moment
is that the prime minister is attracted
to the idea of a cap so you pay up to a
certain level
of your own social care and then the
government steps in but
what level to set that cap especially as
they've promised no one will have to
sell their home
but of course that depends whether your
home is worth a hundred thousand pounds
or
a million pounds will it be the same for
everyone and is that fair
uh also he talked to us uh about double
vaccinations and whether that
potentially would mean
that we could go on holiday or whatever
very different views on either side of
the political
spectrum there that's right the
government really want to do this they
really want
people who've had two jabs to be able to
get out of the quarantine requirements
for the ambalist
countries but it's not going to happen
immediately matt hancock was a bit
cautious there's talk of
august he wouldn't commit to that
because they say
they have to work through all the issues
with it even though dozens of other
countries are doing this the
travel industry are crying out for it
the message from labor is very much one
of
caution we know there's going to be an
update to the green list
later this week not necessarily
something to get excited about i'm told
by sources in government last time they
took a country off it but
going to be updated on friday so
potentially more countries there on
monday but as for the
vaccine passports for double jabbed
people
i think don't get your hopes up quite
yet okay tomorrow for now thanks very
much
indeed apparently costing the economy
something like 600 million pounds a day
at the moment andy murray let's talk
about him he's expressed sympathy for
young players struggling
with the pressure competing at the top
level uh can put on their mental health
following
uh naomi osaka's decision as you know to
withdraw from wimbledon this year
he was speaking to jackie beltran with
less than a week until wimbledon gets
underway she began by asking whether
this would be his last time
playing the tournament in this broadcast
exclusive
to me it's it's not so much necessarily
about uh
i wouldn't say worrying about it being
my last one but it's something that i
think about because
i just have had so many um you know so
many injuries
and so many setbacks that you don't
really know what's around the corner so
i want to try and approach like each
tournament in each match that i play
like it could be my
my last one so that you know i just get
the most out of it
naomi osaka has taken time away from the
tour because she's
struggling with her mental health can
you sympathize
and did you have any mental health
struggles when you were going through
all of your injury setbacks unless
you've been in that situation wouldn't
understand like going from like an 18
year old playing in front of no people
to all of a sudden
playing on wimbledon center core and
being surrounded by
press about your personal life and you
know comments on your personality or how
you might look or how you might talk and
all of those things like
yeah like when you're 18 you're not
prepared for that 1920 you're not not
ready for that and it's a big change so
certainly earlier on in my career i
found it harder dealing with all of the
the the sort of the the press side of
things um
i guess and the attention um whereas now
i have a quite a different perspective
on things so i
you know now is is fine but i can
certainly understand
you know when when athletes do struggle
with them
i've got to ask you about scotland have
you been enjoying the euros
i went to the game the other night and i
don't know if you can tell my
my voice i'm struggling a bit with my
struggling a bit of my voice
you know in the evening we're going down
and having food in the
like in the lobby and watching uh some
of the matches on the big screens and um
yeah it's just nice sort of distraction
really hopefully i hope that scotland
can
can put in a good performance against uh
against croatia on
on tuesday and get through but it will
be tough
i'm going to call this a sport 10
minutes should we because joining us now
is
former formula one world champion none
other than jensen button hello to you
how are you i am sensational thanks for
staying up late
the other side of the world to speak to
us um just before we get on to why
you're joining us today are you a
wimbledon fan
yes i am i've been a couple of times
actually but not for a few years
yeah so you're a big tennis fan who do
you want to win this uh
this uh championship oh
that's a tricky one um i don't know i
for me i just love the
the atmosphere of wimbledon you know i
think it's it's just one of those
special events the only problem is it
normally coincides with the british
grand prix so that's why i've
been able to go as i would like yeah i
thought i'd seen you in
in the royal box with your mum or
somebody in the past i can't i couldn't
quite remember so i thought i would ask
you about it
you're here to talk um about previous uh
grand prix
and the ones that particularly tick your
boxes uh you picked out the 1971 italian
grand prix why is that
actually that's one of the races i
wasn't around for you know that was
before my time
but you know it's it's all about the
racing for me and the reason for
for talking about this now is you know
we're all living our lives and we're all
thinking about the future especially
with what we've been going through with
a pandemic
we're all thinking about the future and
tomorrow and it's nice to take a step
back in time
and look at what we've achieved but also
the sports that we love
and the moments that really stand out of
those sports and
you know i think the six races that
really
that really make a difference have have
made a difference in my life three of
them were from my
racing in formula one but three from uh
iconic races of the past
yeah um particularly 2009 of course now
there was a particular reason why 2009
might have registered in your mind if
you want to remind our viewers
yes uh that was that was the year
actually i won the world championship so
uh
yeah i mean 2009 was a very special year
you know every year in formula one for
me was and you know when i watch formula
one now it's uh
it's great to see that fight at the
front between two two
absolute greats um lewis hamilton and
max verstappen and uh
follow on and then motorsport isn't a
great place at the moment and uh
i'm really excited about the rest of the
season that we have in front of us
monaco grand prix and the brazilian
grand prix in 2009 particularly i'm
guessing the brazilian grand prix
because that's towards the end of the
season isn't it so
is that what you won look at you you
know everything
yes i and monaco was uh was winning and
monaco's a very special place to win i
also parked in the wrong place in monaco
after i won the race so i had to run
down the start and finish line to see
the prince of monaco
which is quite embarrassing but exciting
at the same time
brazil was yesterday clint's the world
title yeah uh
hondo were you i think you were were you
driving for honda in 2009
no that was brawn that was uh when we
were
in 2009 so a very special year because
braun
brought only race for one year in
formula one and it won the world
championship
so uh undefeated yeah you certainly had
well it said that you had the best
uh car on the grid do you think you did
or was it all down to your skill
it was all me 401 is a team sport as we
see you know
lewis hamilton's not winning without a
great car and a great team behind him
so um it's it's about the package but
it's also
it's it's a lot of it's mental you know
racing drivers are all very talented
but it's a mental game and if your head
isn't in the right space
uh you you don't perform so that's uh
that's a big thing with with motorsport
with that in mind how surprised are you
this is a question from my little boy
who's a big f1
fan he says how surprised are you that
daniel ricciardo is struggling
against his much less experienced
teammate lando norris
um at mclaren i
i am surprised actually not taking
anything away from lando norris but
um i know daniel very well and uh every
team he's gone to over the last few
years he's performed pretty much
immediately
but he's gone up against our you know
our young talent one of our
young talents british talents uh lando
norris along with george russell who's
proven himself over the last couple of
years but uh lando
is doing such a good job and uh you know
daniel's struggling a little bit but he
will find his feet this is a very
talented
driver and he's a guy that will be
fighting for the world championship and
in the future along with lando norris
and george russell
do you have any uh thoughts on who might
win this season is it still lewis is to
lose
uh well that's a great thing this year
you know the last few years it's been
it's been mercedes the whole way
but now you have the fight between
mercedes and you have the fight you know
with with red bull
and two fantastic drivers lewis hamilton
and max verstappen so
i'm really enjoying this year you know
i'm doing a lot of stuff with
with sky sports f1 and it's uh it's been
really good because i get to
to talk about this this fantastic fight
and it makes our job really easy because
the racing's so good
how surprised are you that honda uh are
pulling out given that they've got a
sensational car
this year yeah i think it's um
i mean the money that's needed to really
fight at the front in formula one is uh
is it's extremely expensive they've put
a lot of money in over the last few
years i was with
with honda back in 2015 and 16 and we
were struggling a lot
so they've come a long way um but i i
mean what a perfect way to leave the
sport if they do win the world
championship this year
if people don't really get formula one
and they think it's just uh
expensive cars going round and round and
round a track which
race would you particularly point them
towards for them to wet their appetite
and think okay i'm an f1 fan from now on
uh well i think any race from this year
seriously any race from this year they
have all been fantastic and
you know that's not always the case it's
the same with with any sport not every
game or match is
is fantastic and that's why the ones
that stand out are
um but um there are many races this year
that i've i've really enjoyed
um commentating on being a pundit on and
uh
and watching but races from the past i
mean for me
brazil 2000 and 2009 was was pretty
special
canada 2011 which is a four-hour race
and uh i'm not saying it because i won
that race but it was a really exciting
race even if i didn't win it would have
been a great race
yeah i mean you list uh 2011 canadian
grand prix as one of the craziest races
in f1 history why was that
it was the longest race in airport
history they've actually put a limit on
how long a race could be now because uh
there was a red flag in the middle of
the race because of bad weather um but i
i started seventh i crashed with my
teammate lewis hamilton i crashed with
fernando alonso
i did five pit stops i got a drive
through penalty i got a puncher a broken
front wing
i was last twice and i won the race on
the last lap so yeah
it was kind of crazy um and where are
you at the moment why why are you not in
the uk
i mean i live in l.a so uh that's that's
why
i'm here um and it's it's ten to
midnight
right now so seven minutes to write
midnight so if i have red eyes
i have two children two very young
children a two year old and a six month
old so uh
yes um tomorrow's gonna be a tough day
and do you remember when you i
you probably won it more than once
singapore grand prix
when you you won that race didn't you
no i never wanted that oh no were you
second oh i bought some gloves for my
son at auction
that were yours and i said that you'd
won and he's probably listening and now
he knows
that you didn't well let's hope he's not
watching uh but i finished second
okay three times in a second but we can
pretend just
just don't tell him okay well if you're
looking for your gloves they're in my
son's bedroom
it's good to talk to you thank you so
much for joining us go get some sleep
thanks a lot
take care busted uh quick look at
hopefully he's not watching quick look
at the weather if you now here's nas hi
nas
hi morning it's looking fine for many
places this afternoon but there will be
some rain as well
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning we are going to be seeing
mostly fine conditions for many areas
this afternoon but
there will be some rain around in fact
this morning there's rain
slowly but surely clearing from central
and southern parts of england
and wales so into this afternoon these
areas will become a bit brighter and
drier but it may
stay quite cloudy and damp across the
far southeast for most of the day
then elsewhere it's a chilly start but
warming up nicely into this afternoon
with some good spells of sunshine but
becoming cloudier wetter and windier
across the northwest later
the weather sponsored by qatar airways